you ever seen marky
i have zero self-consciousness it's
disgusting maybe i should i mean i don't
think you're aware of it it's literally
like the cookie monster but with like
lasagna no look people go like this
almost everyone who ever sees me eat
because it's a few different things i
mean sloppiness would be one vector but
also the speed at which i eat seems to
frighten people they're like
how many calories do you take a day in
the upper limit is very high i usually
do you know so it's like i only when
we're on the road and we go somewhere
it's like yeah you know but i may eat
ten thousand calories in a day but
normally like three thousand ten
thousand yeah i don't care but the but
but when you eat no one kid but when you
eat uh slow down uh when you eat
do you it's like you eat like you're in
the military like we're rushing you yeah
to go off the floor yeah people will be
like prisons
like the chow like the chow yard like
they don't have a lot of time yeah like
your navy seal and it's like you have
like 20 like you know they have like
something there's no rush
did you grow up with brothers i did and
uh did i though my family grew up
like
not poor but like i just i there was it
wasn't it wasn't yeah like i go over to
other people's houses like oh you guys
have a pantry like that's crazy like you
just have unlimited food
because like that's the gallon of milk
and i'm getting to it before you do so i
don't know but like no that's that i
don't feel any self-conscious about it i
probably should because it immediately
reveals it's like oh this person didn't
grow up with money or whatever it says
there's nothing wrong with that
and food is not abundant yeah you you
get you're not getting seconds unless
you hurry up yeah so you're not seeing
someone eat like mike
i would say speed especially because
people would be like
maybe people could eat more in a contest
or something like that but as far as
pure speed i've never seen anything like
that yeah yeah never in my life like
didn't the kogi truck burrito like it's
a korean barbecue burritos you ate it my
friend even i got six of those in five
minutes without a drink like or i should
say my the bet was that i could eat six
i got the sixth one in my mouth
i feel like you're not enjoying the food
that's sort of that's what bothers me
right you're not tasting i do because my
taste buds function but people i always
say that they're like you know you're
not tasting the food i am
and that's what makes me want more of it
i know i could it's
for example when i go to a nice
restaurant like a french restaurant or
something i do i'll be like oh man every
bite is really good and i do know what
that feels like to do that um but
sometimes i feel like you like putting
away the food i'll be like oh [ __ ] i
need to pretend like i eat slow right i
was gonna say when you go on a date is
your girl like hey man yes it's almost
like farting in front of a girl it's
like oh now you know that i like do
these gross things i have enough
self-consciousness to be like if i'm
trying to impress somebody
i won't eat like a maniac but yeah
it's the default marquee it's like jabba
the hutt on the road man